my body was in a place you know in my
teen years and when i first came onto
the channel
that i wasn't um completely my most
confident but for the most part
i feel very happy with where i am
miranda may was just a teenager when she
got her start on the disney channel
hey guys it's miranda may from bunk now
she's all grown up
and at 24 the brunette beauty could lead
a master class in confidence
especially when it comes to her journey
with health and fitness
am i the smallest i've ever been no am i
happy
yes am i healthy absolutely miranda it's
been such an honor and a pleasure to
watch you grow from
this young woman into such an empowered
woman
right before our very eyes and i i want
to just
talk a little bit about this amazing
health journey that you really welcomed
your fans in on
how do you react when you see you know
maybe your older work or your older head
shots
and and where you are today it's crazy
it feels like two different people for
me
um thank you by the way for those kind
words um
it does you know i feel like every point
in our life
is supposed to happen the way it's
supposed to happen and um i was
fortunate enough to go on a journey that
made me healthy but it also made me very
happy
and um you know having so many people
watch that journey and inspire them
has been the best part because i mean
i'm not perfect you know we all lose and
we gain weight we go on this yoyo we're
women
it's just how our bodies are programmed
they're not you know they're not going
to stay the same forever for most of us
and um you know my body was
in a place you know in my teen years and
when i first came onto the channel
that i wasn't um completely my most
confident i'm such a confident
personality such a confident person
that i want my exterior to match my
interior you know
and so it made me so happy to work out
and to become healthier and
more confident in that way because i
think
a first impression is something you can
never obviously redo
and i want to walk into a room and i
feel like i completely am sure of myself
and happy with myself every time that i
do that and i feel like i'm able to do
that now
and as i get older i feel so confident
each day and that we obviously
have bad days but for the most part i
feel
very happy with where i am so yeah it's
been great and it's inspired so many
people so that's awesome
it's that same positivity that miranda
brings to her character lou
on bunked who you'll see in the upcoming
disney channel crossover special
raven about bunkt camp will never be
the same we might lose the camp i was
just trying to build suspense tell me
about this special
and what does it mean for disney channel
it's a big deal honestly this is the
first crossover in a very long time and
i think for the channel
it's a big deal because these two shows
people love them so much and to see
these worlds collide and then to have
fun together and go on an adventure we
love seeing
both of these shows go on adventures so
for them to do
a massive one is insane i think
everybody's heads are just gonna explode
because there's so much to take in
um so much fun to be had um and i'm
excited for everybody to see the
relationships
of you know one cast with another and
now
you know they all become friends and
we're friends off screen so it made it
ten times more believable and fun to
watch and fun to make
um yeah i think it's exciting raven how
you feeling
i feel the same way miranda does i'm
excited to
be able to say that i worked with
miranda and the cast of bunked because
they have been
going strong on disney channel for many
years
and it feels so good to sit next to
my disney sisters and make some content
it feels great
you